oh no
what a start to the adobe flash
tournament there we go
e4 best buy test stay focused grab
central space maybe push your opponent
around with e5
all right
take with the knight i need to keep him
defended
push
okay i'm still thinking about it let's
go here first
here queen f3 and then push
get my rook working
what's that move doing
hitting at c2 let's give him a kick he's
sent he's decentralized there let's open
up the f file and this diagonal
might want to just sack the knight if
takes here let's do this first
this could be big trouble fast now queen
here main two two or three threat
okay how do they block
okay this is meeting
the knight has to block and then there's
mate here
there's only these knight g4 queen g5
stuff back to tournament two
okay
game one
game two is where there was a big speed
bump in the last tournament
no speed bumps allowed
all right let's get developed
i'm going to take here i'm going to
launch an h-pawn
let's go for it
all right long-term idea in mind with
that one day i'm looking for back rank
stuff
there's no pound here to grab
there's no pawn there to grab
okay now that bishop is dead
a dead bishop
so now i'm certainly looking for
some stuff here
for lack of better words
oh what are you looking for just some
stuff
some stuff is all i want really
knight's e5 he's intolerable that bishop
is remaining dead he's officially a
cooked bishop who says my bishop's bad
their bishop's bad they're playing
without a bishop
let's trade rooks
no okay
yeah make up your mind i would have
played rook there if that happened i'm
not sure what i'm even talking about
pawn push
let's trade rooks you're playing without
a bishop there we go
playing without a bishop
where's that bishop going
oh man
that bishop is suffering
that's as far as i want to go though
as far as i want to go oh no he's going
to be rescued
my king is fast too
isn't he
oh no he's gonna come back over
push
push
take him he's free
or is he
take him because he's free or is he
i like my pawn he's too valuable
are we doing on time
not very good
i could take this guy
i think
um
check
oh i thought i lost on time and they
lost on time
i think i lost a lot of time
continually staring at that bishop that
was stuck in the corner their king came
to the rescue eliminating a pun and he
was free
this the prisoner escaped
oh man
oh man that's all i could say after each
game is just oh man
oh my goodness there's another one
make up your mind what's it gonna be
oh queen h5
i'm not sacking any pieces let's get
here
that night's going to arrive on a deadly
square a deadly square
knight here
take my bishop
damage my pawn structure at the cost of
eliminating a super good knight
there he is
he can't be tolerated
no i can't get to f1 that's a problem
all right
shut down the bishop is phase one
bishop d3 is nice though
okay he shut down pun push oh no
i saw that no i didn't
you're lying now
you're lying now
you lost that piece
okay i gotta go fast
bishop's hit
i have a pass pun
i gotta save this guy bishop here is
good maybe
yes it is
i gotta run fast oh i thought they were
gonna take with the rook first i didn't
mean to do that
oh
my pawns gonna be fast hopefully
king position oh rook here is good
dodged a bullet
made threats
made threat
um
i can't stop their pun
or can i
what's their clock situation not very
good
oh
they should somehow still be winning
i don't even know what that is oh my god
i won a time oh my god another ugly ugly
ugly game
a rat race again oh
man
oh it's just too intense
oh it's just way too intense what can i
say
that one took the wind out of me
oh
i'm speechless i'm done commentating
oh
okay i was gonna play um i was gonna
play b5 if they gave me an opportunity
to do that
is c4
shut the bishop down
okay trying to break down this structure
okay
let's take here and give a check maybe
no matter what
let's go here that was probably not not
the greatest pre-move oh
let's take here defend the rook and grab
a pawn
all right there's gonna be oh that's a
free piece
um
right here counter punch after a capture
um let's get out of pins
he's a loose piece right here
these guys offset he's a dead piece
let's kick that knight away he's
definitely a prisoner now
another cooked bishop
all right well he's trying to free him
let's just back up and defend stuff 21
seconds
go
here night here move forward
move forward throw a knight in here
welcome exchanges
exchanges please move your bishop
i need flight square
just in case anything bad happens
queen is hit and so is the bishop
okay
h2
i'm on the rook
backrank stuff
let's take here background stuff again
whoa
that's me back to tournament oh i have
so little time
30 30 29 25 20.
wow we're only eight men's eight minutes
in
we can't even say the word minutes
okay knight c3
let me try a gambit
have three
all right i got the f file
pinpoint f7
maybe queenside castle
well what do you think you're doing here
this
and i have an isolated pawn here
uh
don't really like to pull the rook off
of this pawn here but
let's give this guy a kick
get some tempo gaining moves why am i
allowing this pin do i not realize
there's a pin here
oh man
bishop back up
and break the pin get on this diagonal
they have a very good defense
look at my time
wow
wow 22 seconds you gotta move
move
fast
really fast
okay i need to smash through on that
square
let's just do this it's not good but
i gotta try something
gotta try something
okay this is getting a piece back
because i recapture here
oh oh i take the knight with check
13 seconds
i take here that's discover check
upon push
rook takes and then if the king goes to
the corner it's mate here
that's me i needed that oh
56 42 42 37
30
30
30.
do you really have to read off all those
numbers no you don't
okay
c5 smith mora declined declined
e6
i don't want to deal with that open c
file i like having this square for my
queen
unless the bishop plays there
i was gonna say i don't like having the
rook opposite my queen let's chase that
bishop off of the diagonal get out of
there my queen wants to be on c7 okay so
there's some concession here this pawn
is unprotected because the pawn is
pinned on f2
queen c7
back up all the way stay out of the way
knight c5 with tempo the bishop moves
the knights dropping in here queen takes
g3 is available
let's do this there's some sacrifices
over here
f6 next i want to open this up
i definitely need to undermine a knight
if he wants to drop into this square
light square weaknesses oh man let's try
this
let's try this maybe my king cannot make
use of f8 if i'm in check i might have
to give back the
not give back the exchange but just give
up the exchange oh i'm getting this
i get uh i get the queen
or the exchange
what's their choice gonna be okay let's
make this
let's make a rook exchange
here probably no matter what
and then i'm opening up this diagonal
again
let's just take immediately oh bishop
check on h7
okay oh that's a free rook and more
stuff is falling now
let's check
let's take here and then
made threat on g2
oh i thought you went to g2
oh then you take the queen
oh man
okay back to tournament they resigned 72
72 56 55 54. eight games in i only have
six
man they're flying
oh he he's one of the 56 guys
for lack of a better phrase he's one of
the 56 guys oh i know exactly who you're
talking about
on queen here i just want to stop that
all together
so we just had my bad bishop for their
good bishop exchanged
all right
i'll take here and just challenge this
guy right
away i'm gonna have c5
let's try to break open here no now they
don't have c5
take like this i don't want the b file
to open up
let's keep this shut down take towards
the center
over here
let's break
in between her
and then recapture d4
that bishop's in a pin i just want to
glue my queen on this square let's get a
flight square oh that queen's gone
rook takes that's another pin something
similar happened in the last game
i have a flight square just come back
here no matter what here
secure my bishop
grab pawns i didn't mean to do that
it's a check
check the rook has to block i get the
rook
uh two moves
it's me back determined that was fairly
quick
not without the help of my opponent that
queen f6 move that
certainly helped out a lot
72-72
grabs a lot
grabs
a lot
is this guy going to move
he's not moving quick resigner
he's going to play f4 no he's going to
play the grub
who would have thought
right this is the grub isn't it g4 most
committal move to start a chess game
wow
going right after b7
losing my voice
let's secure my pawn he's super valuable
i should have considered knight
recapture why not plant your piece in
your opponent's position with tempo
there goes their light square bishop
these guys are very weak in h3 and f3
bishop d6 before their bishop gets on
this diagonal
just get every piece out quick let's
grab a pun and develop
grab upon and develop
night out castle rookie eight
bishop to g3 a lot of juicy options here
gain a tempo against the queen with rook
b8 half open file here
probably no matter what i want to kick a
knight out of this square
i don't want to capture the knight
i wanted to pull my bishop back and play
f5
pin the knight
i have f4 regarded
the queen is kind of out of play here
here probably here no matter what no i
should have taken the knight oh well
take them now
and looking for something on h1 rook
here
not quite working
let's get another piece involved
rook here and then some discovery check
they're down on time back to tournament
110 88 72
all right
d4
a chance here i have a chance where
where are we time-wise in the tournament
still plenty of time forks
kill the knight and then land a fork
oh it's a thinker
it's a thinker
here no matter what oh that king's gonna
get beat up they resigned back to
tournament that's what i needed 110 90.
that became very awkward
queen trade and knight being on d5
looking to get into c7 remove the knight
on a6 110 90 88.88
halfway point only there's nine games in
okay
14 minutes
all right
let's try c5 check benoni
d5 e5
okay i get a tempo against the queen
quick move here
queens off i have elite in development
maybe now
not now
look to remove the knight and jump in
here
let's try right now
that's a fork
out that rook let's pin the knight
make sure he does not end up
on this square here
pile up on the pinned
piece to land a check first now i'm now
i'm going to be up a full rook they
should have taken that guy as soon as
possible
let's castle with check and get the
other rook involved
throwing a check no
i'm up a rook here
king position king position
making a lot of moves fast
my pawn is passed i mean to do that
making a lot of king moves
a lot of king moves here here and then
mate back to tournament 110
130 110 108 108 105.
okay
about 12 minutes remain in this one why
do i keep going with this setup there's
got to be something more aggressive
there's got to be something out there
more aggressive than the london setup
right
you take my knight it's a fork
it is officially a fork
rook up and over
i almost tried to just do that in one
move
patience
patience i know you're eager
oh that king is running for the hills
all right let's throw rook opposite the
king
how bad can that be right land a fork on
f5
make sure that bishop doesn't get out of
control
why'd i do that get out of there unpin
my knight please
let's take here and then here rook here
is a good move
um
let's just
play here
counter pin oh i could take the queen oh
there goes my queen
oh man those lateral movements with the
queen at least i get a rook somehow is
this gonna be good i drop my queen i
love my queen i dropped her
oh no
dangerous pin
dangerous dangerous pin
very dangerous pin
super dangerous
i'm gonna get mated
definitely gonna get mated
why didn't they why what are they doing
i'm getting a queen back
no way only 5.4 seconds
dangerous
gonna take here
four seconds
oh i made it
they had me didn't they
oh no no no
oh i'm down on time that was so ugly oh
i just went i think i had my queen
picked up and i was like oh i'm just
gonna take the queen and they took mine
just like that gone she was
that will not be the last time i lose my
queen to some lateral movement
ah that's such a blind spot not just for
me everybody i think
back to tournament what's going on
oh that's
a much needed boost there after a loss
oh that king was running for the hills
too
right he was on f8
e7 running into line of fire there were
fireworks everywhere land mines
everywhere
okay
all right let's get this pawn here he's
a freebie
trouble with the mouse
okay
you still have this
let's get developed let's secure this i
need a flight square
flight square where are you at now is
not the time for flight square
potential annoying pin on the d file
tonight free night
three pieces now
on the rook
and another piece
pile up on the pinned piece bishop goes
somewhere
hang on
get rid of that bishop
it's too good
crash through on this square knight g5 i
gotta go quicker
what's that move even doing
okay and i'll try to get back here
he's stopping me
okay mate here happening soon
kill him and then here no matter what
even if he's taken
back to tournament they resigned 155 148
i can still try to get up there
less than nine minutes 170 i think i'm
gonna get paired up with this top guy no
i just saw him get up there
i thought i thought i was gonna get
paired up nope
all right tempo
tempo against the queen d5
okay i can't get that in so easily
get the tempo against that queen with a
rook on c8
soon they're gonna queenside castle
secure my pawn here if they do that
if i go here anyhow
all right they're gonna take my knight
i'm not sure how it would take back
i want to secure this square i don't
want to have an isolated pond i don't
want they're nice to have homes that
knight's pinned
and he's not doing anything about that
pinned piece so i got
a piece now
and
oh ooh i got a queen now
i know the feeling i definitely know the
feeling
i just came from a game where i lost a
queen
i know that feeling it's very painful
not want to wish that on anybody
never
knight c3 e4
let's make sure i keep a pawn here
an annoying pawn on
keep
d5
space advantage i'm getting tempo
against that queen after rook e1
so it's a bit of a clumsy setup here
whoa really at the end of it rook to e1
queen is dead
let's hang on to my queen this game
let's try that
let's get a knight back into that d5
square
sorry i lost my voice there
wow
let's go
here we're opposite sides castling i
should be looking for c3
c3b4 stuff
here bishop here
just develop aggressively
bishop here bishop f4
let's just go one step
take this pawn would you knight here and
the queen could be gone
that night has to go
right
and rook up and over
bishop f6
i go rook to b8 rook to b3
okay there queen's gone now
and
okay
that's me back to tournament 188 228 210
188 188
six minutes remain
okay
um
let's try this again
knight c6
and go for a quick kingside castle and
on the night
take it towards the center so i could
build it up with d5 at some point
okay
i'm still going to go for it to pry open
the h file
let's shut down that bishop
g5
no let's continue
i want to wreck my structure
bishop here and then pawn push though
this rook is opposite my king if there's
no longer an e4 pawn
could be a problem
let's open it up
and
queenside castle double rooks
if king
let's do it now
i think it's right i'm throwing a fork
okay now i have made on h1 after pawn
push
it's going to be brutal
there's pawn push move threatening mate
on each one
could be a quick win
easy to miss
where is it
on the knight the bishop threatening
mate that's me
back to term at 208
230 26 208
oh this is this is the top guy
let's see
this guy's flying
throw a check in there to slow him down
maybe
how do they get their minor pieces
coordinated
all right let's stop the b5 push
still
i'm gonna be on d6 a bunch of times i'm
gonna push
i think i'm gonna get that pawn they
can't do they have enough pieces on it
yeah they do okay
i'm okay with this trade i want to have
a pawn here
a bishop here
look here trade get an active rook
i want to get this file
all to myself stop the wreck from
getting active
rook where
here
not so great
you can scoop up this pawn
sorry i'm losing my voice here
rook here to block
and
let's trade
right
we won king and pawn ending if we trade
these pawns pushing i should have just
pushed here
this is where i have an advantage
um
not doing this so well
stop these pawns from going any further
okay king position
get these pawns running
okay
take here
here
and just get running
i'm getting this
10 seconds is plenty of time you can
resign
the time tick
back to tournament 228 that was a big
win 250 228 224 two minutes remain um
two wins out from trying to catch that
guy um
i think i need to try and win this to
secure second i don't think i think this
is gonna be the last game
unless something crazy happens
hmm
okay oops let's try here bishop oh
let's take that guy would they resign
they'd be perfect oh it's a free piece
they didn't take back knight takes was
needed
sorry to give a piece back with b6 my
net would be hanging
jump in here or take on c4
e4
let's take that pawn queen is coming off
no
take with the rook they resigned back to
chairman 250 246 150. i can still get
this
well that guy's maybe ready to win
though
if that that guy the game he's in right
now he's gonna if he wins he's got it
pretty sure no
let's try this
it's not a good move i think i think
takes here
and i would have been in trouble
zero compensation for being down upon
knight f6 i push now the queen is
indirectly defending that
queen a5 stuff
um
grab that pawn right
okay i gotta move my knight
defend here
not sure what that's doing i don't want
to allow the h file to open up
whoa i got their queen
would they resign they resigned back to
tournament 268.
is that that guy going to win i need to
try to get one more in 268 250 243
i need to try tricky stuff here tricky
stuff scholars mates
scholars mates scholar mate night here
scholar me
g3 queen back
uh
not happening you gotta go for cheap
tricks sometimes
that was one of those times
oh what's that that's a freak queen no
not quite
not quite a free queen
i tried
okay i need to get my light square
bishop out that's for sure
hang on let's back up
they're calling the tournament
he probably won right
back to tournament what is it oh i got
first where's the confetti
they don't give it out for these created
tournaments
oh that guy didn't win
wow
oh man good games oh
not a squeaky clean tournament no one in
fact up top here had a squeaky clean
performance
no
same numbers here
19
19 games in
10 game
streak 20 games in nine game winning
streak everybody slipped up
nobody was perfect
all right 268 253 250 super tight pack
up here
oh man
you